ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE
PRESIDENT'S TEAM HAS ALREADY
TOLD THE COMMITTEE THAT HE
ORIGINATED THAT IDEA.
MORE NOW FROM RANDI KAYE.
>> THIS IS AN ATTACK BY OTHER
COUNTRIES, FOREIGN COUNTRIES, IS
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
>> I BELIEVE FROM WHAT I HAVE
SEEN AND THE WITNESSES I HAVE
TALKED TO THAT THIS IS A COUP.
>> THAT'S JAMES PHIL WALDREN, A
RETIRED U.S. ARMY COLONEL
PUSHING HIS BASELESS CLAIMS OF
ELECTION FRAUD.
HE SPECIALIZED IN PSYCHOLOGICAL
OPERATIONS DURING HIS MILITARY
CAREER, AND SAYS HE CONDUCTED
ELECTRONIC WARFARE AND
COUNTERDECEPTION.
TODAY, HE OWNS A BAR IN TEXAS,
BUT JUST AFTER THE 2020
ELECTION, HE WAS BUSY TESTIFYING
BEFORE LEGISLATURES IN
BATTLEGROUND STATES ABOUT HIS
NOW LONG DEBUNKED CLAIMS THAT
VOTING SYSTEMS WERE MANIPULATED
IN THE ELECTION.
>> WE SAW NUMEROUS EXAMPLES OF
NUMBERS MOVING, NUMBERS BEING
FLIPPED AND SWITCHED.
>> TO BE CLEAR, THEN PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP'S OWN JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FOUND NO EVIDENCE OF
WIDESPREAD FRAUD THAT WOULD HAVE
CHANGED THE ELECTION RESULTS.
BUT THAT DIDN'T STOP WALDREN
FROM CONTRIBUTING TO AND
CIRCULATING A POWERPOINT
DOCUMENT DETAILING WAYS TO
UNDERMINE THE 2020 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION OUTCOME.
THE POWERPOINT BASELESSLY CLAIMS
CHINA AND VENEZUELA TOOK CONTROL
OF THE U.S. ELECTION SYSTEM,
CREATING A NATIONAL SECURITY
EMERGENCY.
>> THE LINKS THAT GO BACK TO
CHINA KEEP GROWING.
>> THE DOCUMENT ALSO RECOMMENDS
THAT ELECTRONIC VOTING IN ALL
STATES BE DECLARED INVALID.
IT SUGGESTS U.S. MARSHALS SECURE
ALL BALLOTS AND PROVIDE A
PROTECTIVE PERIMETER AROUND THE
LOCATIONS IN ALL 50 STATES.
IN SUMMARY, THE DOCUMENT SAYS,
IF YOU COUNT THE PAPER BALLOTS
IN EACH STATE, TRUMP WINS
OVERWHELMINGLY.
>> THESE SYSTEMS ALL HAVE BACK
DOORS.
>> THIS POWERPOINT DOCUMENT
WASN'T JUST SHARED AMONG
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS AND THOSE
WORKING TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION
RESULTS.
IT MADE ITS WAY TO THE WHITE
HOUSE AND THE HALLS OF CONGRESS.
AND SO DID PHIL WALDREN.
WALDREN DIDN'T RESPONT TO OUR
REQUEST FOR COMMENT, BUT HE TOLD
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HE VISITED
THE WHITE HOUSE MULTIPLE TIMES
AND SPOKE WITH THEN TRUMP CHIEF
OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS, MAYBE
EIGHT TO TEN TIMES.
THE CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATING THE INSURRECTION
AT THE CAPITOL RELEASED THIS
LETTER, SAYING MEADOWS HAD
TURNED OVER THE POWERPOINT
DOCUMENT TO THE COMMITTEE.
WALDREN TOLD "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" THAT HE DID NOT DIRECTLY
SEND THE DOCUMENT TO MEADOWS BUT
THAT PERHAPS SOMEONE ON HIS TEAM
HAD PASSED IT ALONG TO HIM.
WALDREN ALSO TOLD "THE
WASHINGTON POST" THAT HE BRIEFED
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ON HIS
UNFOUNDED CLAIMS OF ELECTION
FRAUD.
THE PAPER SAYS THAT GROUP
INCLUDED SENATORS RON JOHNSON
AND LINDSEY GRAHAM.
IN ADDITION TO SOME HOUSE
MEMBERS.
NOW, THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATING THE JANUARY 6th
ATTACK HAS ALSO SUBPOENAED
WALDREN.
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN BENNIE
THOMPSON SAYING IN A STATEMENT,
THE DOCUMENT HE REPORTEDLY
PROVIDED TO ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS AND MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS IS AN ALARMING
BLUEPRIN